you've probably heard that we're living
in the Golden Age of television or maybe
it's the platinum image whatever the
point is TV is way better than it used
to be and you could say the same thing
for TV title sequences the video
introductions to each show they used to
be after thoughts a bunch of b-roll
clips and actors staring into the camera
but now their artistic statements of
their own they can be bittersweet Berner
jeddak or the sad
in the streaming era when we watch our
favorite programs anywhere and at
anytime
titles help get us in the right mood
even if we're in the middle of our
morning commute
you know the main title sequence is
functions a little bit like an airlock
between everyday life and the state that
you going to when you come back to what
you show that's Patrick Clair creative
director of elastic an L a production
studio he's the force behind title
sequences like AMC's halt and catch fire
and HBO's Westworld he says the
revolution in title sequences kicked in
in the mid 90s when new software
programs like Adobe's Creative Suite
unlocked the potential of a new
generation of designers at the same time
we started watching TV differently
before then most TV shows were episodic
viewers checked in from time to time but
they didn't have to watch every episode
credits helped introduce new viewers who
were just tuning in for the first time
sometimes they go so far as to explain
the show's entire premise by the 1990s
some shows were breaking that mold
one early standout was the title
sequence for The Fresh Prince of bel-air
which was more like a music video than
the title sequence in fact it was
directed by the same guy who directed
The Fresh Prince's video for parents
just don't understand
and you can see how similar they are but
that was just early rumblings of the
revolution that would really hit a few
years later
[Music]
when you watch that I mean everybody
kind of took a step back and was like
wait a minute what what's happening
that's Lola land kick and we'll Perkins
who run a website called the art of the
title they point out that this sequence
does the opposite of what most titles do
it hides way more than it reveals Tony's
the only character and you never really
see him the editing the cinematography
cuts Tony up you don't see him full
figure you see his cigar you see his
eyes and see his hands on the wheel you
don't get a full picture of him until
the very end when he gets out who is
this guy yeah and that's and that's the
show right with the Sopranos
HBO assured in a new wave of prestige
television and its title sequences were
equally ambitious instead of the usual
30 seconds they were allowed to run for
60 or even 90 seconds designers were
encouraged to discover new techniques
like placing two-dimensional drawings
and 3d space are using found footage and
new ways to create a kind of tone poem
those examples inspired Patrick Claire
when he designed what would become one
of the most famous title sequences of
the modern era true detective
the basic idea came from Clara's first
call with the showrunner and director in
the show that we're using the broken
polluted landscapes to talk about the
the broken poison to people that were in
the narrative and these kinds of these
people that have been exploited and and
and destroyed by um by what had happened
to them and so that just seemed in very
literal terms to be well I guess we'll
just make broken portraits out of broken
landscapes the showrunners already had a
song they wanted to use so Claire
started putting together books full of
images that spoke to this feeling of
brokenness one main source was a book
called petrochemical America by
photographer Richard mizerock his team
also figured out a way to take footage
from the show and slow it down to
one-tenth speed which lent it a
dreamlike quality and he ended the
sequence in flames another idea that was
inspired by his conversation with the
show's creators the these are characters
who are facing a personal apocalypse and
and that's made of opened the door
something I would have gone into this
world of literally this is a biblical
apocalypse true detective was hugely
influential
maybe a little too influential but
there's a lot more than just Moody
HBO dramas out there we're seeing all
kinds of different networks and shows
take on ambitious title sequences we're
seeing titles that focus on type like
stranger things and mr. robots we're
seeing postmodern title sequences the
play with the conventions of internet
videos or musical comedy we've seen
remixes
and guest artists we've even seen title
sequences without any shows attached if
you think about it
TV titles are kind of like what music
videos used to be a design medium that
started as a kind of advertisement but
became its own form of artistic
expression and just as MTV became a
breeding ground for a generation of
artists the people who were making
today's TV title sequences maybe
tomorrow's film directors visual artists
or show runners themselves